hello and welcome to barrel e's journey
to the cloud today we'll shout a bit
about verily who we are in our
background how we're developing in the
cloud my team barely kuhmo and how we're
enabling that development in partnership
with alphabet cloud some of the products
we've worked together to build to kind
of enable that cloud development to be
more efficient the adoption catalysts of
those products and then deep dive into
one of the more recent products for
excited about verily cloud or app
Factory and then we'll wrap it up by
chatting about we're barely looking for
the rest of 2020 in the cloud but first
we should do introductions hello I'm
Sarah Chow ski I work at barely on a
team called kuhmo and I'm joined by Tony
Tseng from alphabet cloud in Google so
verily verily as alphabets venture in
healthcare we're focused on a focused
version of googles mission to make the
world's health information useful so
that people enjoy a healthier lives we
sit at the crux of healthcare research
engineering and data informatics and
we're focused on an exponential
improvement of care so farily was
founded as Google life sciences in
Google X in 2013 we've grown since then
changed our name to barely and we now
have over a thousand employees in barely
and joint ventures we work with 32 top
tier Pharma and medical device companies
and we partner in three different spaces
we partner across care solutions where
we work with health health systems and
employers to develop tools and
interventions optimizing care delivery
we work in research solutions creating
an ecosystem of sponsors and health
systems to accelerate studies to make it
easier to generate evidence and finally
we collaborate in innovation solutions
working together on next-gen devices
connected and connected solutions that
empower research and Claire care outside
the four walls of a clinic so one
product fairly works on is project
baseline project baseline collects and
organizes terabytes of data use the
future of understanding comprehensive
health we collect data from traditional
sources like clinic health care records
as well as from more non-traditional
sources like data
at home about behavior and medication
and remote wearable devices and location
we pulls together this data and
organized and aggregated and using the
project baseline ecosystem we've built
we improve the speed and quality of
evidence generation of other companies
in pharma device and health systems so
that they can focus on what they do best
we sit at the center to connect
participants to studies and develop
technology to enable studies to move
more efficiently and as you can imagine
these partners and participants have
varying needs and different
infrastructure and we want to meet them
where they are and kind of collaborate
in a public cloud which has led us to
developing in the cloud as I said we
gained several benefits from the cloud
one of which is Co development and data
sharing with partners we also get fast
development and prototyping from the
cloud we reduce new higher ramp up time
because all of the tool chains are tool
chains that new hires are more familiar
with as their public and finally we help
Google dog food it's GCP cloud offering
dog food is a tradition at alphabet
where we kind of preview and work with
products before they hit market and kind
of provide feedback and help fine-tune
these products so very least GCP history
as you can see our use of GCP has just
gone up into the right
we've been adopting GCP over the course
of years and we've hit a lot of the same
cloud adoption pain points that all GCD
customers hit a sample of these prot
hard challenges include management of
external partners access to data making
sure that if their agreements to
acknowledge that these partners do so
before seeing data and that their
membership would expire in a timely
manner and possibly be refreshed we work
to audit cloud resources and their
access make sure I am policies are
exactly what we want them to be and that
we understand who who is accessing our
data and have technical leads just kind
of check on and audit these accesses and
resources configuration from time to
time
and finally just streamline of creation
and management of apps and resources and
as we kind of hit some of these
roadblocks they've pushed us to create
new pieces of information
structured to solve these common pain
points together with fairly and alphabet
I'm an alphabet cloud is in the process
of production izing and releasing these
products
so my team barely kuhmo is one of the
central cloud native teams at Fairleigh
I learned possibly too many months into
my tenure on kuhmo that Kumu means cloud
in Japanese which is quite fitting for
our team our mission is to make Early's
use of the cloud safer simpler and more
secure by default we work with teams in
farily and understand their use cases
and iterate on their cloud resource
management we collaborate with fairly
DevOps
to promote reliable and sustainable
software developed practices kuma
manages I am best practices and enforces
word policies on our GCP resources to
kind of make sure that those resources
are following the guidelines may need
them to and finally we help develop
custom tariffs or modules these are
fairly specific tariffs or modules that
enforce
best practices consistency and security
and they're used throughout the company
both directly and as you'll see later in
at factory as well and as I said my team
Colima collaborates with alphabet cloud
to do all of this so I'll hand it over
to Tony to talk about a bit about his
team Thank You Sara
hi everyone I'm Tony and one of the
techniques in the alphabetical team at
Google so our team was formed about two
and a half years ago and our team's
mission is to enable GCP adoption across
affect companies so that ultimately we
can improve our platform and the overall
customer experience in other words we're
here to reduce friction so in the past
two-and-a-half years we have been using
GCP like an external customer would and
we've seen our share of friction points
I'm going to quickly go over three
examples here and I suspect some of you
might have seen them before too
the first example is the steel - my
sequel connectivity so the MPLS in this
permissive mode does not work with my
sequel you will need either need to
change too strict or disable MPLS
altogether this is a well-documented
issue by now but once in a while new
people will still hit it a second
example is automatic HTTP to HTTPS
so earlier this year Google cloud load
balancer Renata's feature but before it
was available we have to add another
layer of low balancer in order to do
this redirect the third example is about
GCP api enablement so in our tariffs all
modules will need to conditionally wait
for an api to be enabled before we can
do any kind of operation otherwise it's
going to result in the air so for some
of these friction points we'll try to
add internal priority so that the fixes
can be rolled out sooner and for others
we've created workarounds and custom
solutions so as the next step of custom
solutions we have launched three
internal products within barelly the
first products called barely groups
barely groups as an application layer
they don't have a Google Groups he has
two additional features the first one is
membership expiration barely there's no
which groups have permanent members
therefore all members will have an
expiration period and also when the
expiration time approaches notifications
will be sent out to both a group admin
and remember the second key feature is
about data agreements so some of these
groups are used for access control
purposes so before a member can gain
access to a group they have to
acknowledge some usage agreements and
when an acknowledgment has been made
will have to be renewed periodically the
second product is called additive so
additive is a service that offers
security audit and cost control
governance for verily it ingests GCT
resource metadata audit logs and I am
policies in order to generate periodic
periodic reviews of reports for early
lease to review it also has integration
with config validator so that it can
scan for anomalies and violations in GCP
resource configuration and finally the
third product is called barely cloud
barely cloud is a coronet ease based
application platform created by us in
collaboration with barely teams we liked
it a lot so far and we're planning to
make it available extreme
under the name of app factory so for the
rest of this presentation you might hear
the names verily hell and a factory
being used interchangeably the initial
motivation for us to create a factory is
to reduce the time to service the one
common complaint that we keep hearing
over and over again is that it takes too
long for a new team to get started on
cloud oftentimes a developer will spend
a lot of time learning about GCV
configuration details and their internal
security standards now both of these are
really important but they don't
meaningfully contribute to the quality
of software development deployment they
also don't change very much from team to
team therefore our hypothesis is that by
offering an opinion a platform with
automatic garrulous we can significantly
reduce this ramp up time there are four
key features of a factory the first one
is about cloud resource configurations
app Factory enables you to define custom
abstractions of cloud resources backed
by tariffs or modules to use an analogy
instead of a hardware store that sells
nuts and bolts app factory should be
more like a furniture store that sells
fully assembled desks and chairs in this
basic usage you can have a one-to-one
mapping between a factory resources and
cloud resources
the only difference there is that you
may take away a lot of settings and
replace them with fixed values that are
appropriate for your specific
application but for most applications
they need more than just a cloud sequel
instance or just a GCS bucket or just a
puff subtopic they actually need a suite
of different gcd resources to work
together as a cohesive unit so a factory
enables you to define this higher level
of abstraction so that your developers
will only need to deal with a single
logical entity as opposed to the 5 or 6
or 10 different hobby sources the second
key feature is about rapid application
development
as a developer I want to get to the
business logic part as fast as possible
I'm not very interested in the
boilerplate or boostrap code app Factory
enables you to bring your own set of
service templates for your developers to
build on it is much easier to start from
a working example than to start from
scratch the third feature is about the
integration with git repositories so all
the configurations are stored in the
gated repository so with a version
control system we get a few benefits for
free we have code reviews we have audit
logs we have the ability to rollback we
can also plug in pre-summit checks and
finally app factory as a bridge between
clique ops
and get ops we recognize that not
everybody is an emo enthusiast somebody
or some of us still prefer to work with
web UI so a Fafi can take the input from
web UI and generate a corresponding pull
request and also depending on your
specific setup you can choose to skip
the review part and commit directly to
the git repository and next we're going
to show a demo of a factory and after
the demo Sarah will go over the roam app
this is a demo for verily cloud verily
cloud is an internal application
platform built on kubernetes it's proven
to be quite useful so far and we are
exploring its utility as an external
product offering under the name app
Factory in this demo we're going to show
the workflow to create a cloud
environment on GCP and to deploy a
simple application the first step is to
create a product a product on barely
cloud roughly maps to a set of git
repositories cloud environments and
software services in terms of GCP
resource hierarchy you can think of a
product as a folder and there is one GCP
project per environment underneath the
folder to contain the environment
specific resources now let's go to the
product creation screen
other than the name and description you
will see that there are also the I am
groups and break glass groups the I am
groups have read-only permissions on
prot and pre prod environments the break
glass groups have full access break
clause comes from the phrase in case of
emergency break glass access to the
group is based on demand issue only be
done when there is a need to make
emergency changes and the membership has
a short expression time at the bottom
here you'll see that verily cloud
creates five environments by default
that's based on barely standard
engineering practice and it is
completely customizable now I'm going to
enter the Prada parameters and start the
creation process going back to the prot
of the screen you can see that the
product is now in the pending creation
state here is where every early cloud
makes the connection between click ops
and get ups barely claw has generated a
github PO request based on the product
parameters that we have specified
earlier is showing pending creation
because the pour request has not been
merged yet let's review the pull
requests this pull request contains
multiple files and directories there is
one directory per environment and if we
scroll all the way down we'll see a
product IMO file that contains the
product specification I like the career
attention to these two fields every
product has a config repo in the
deployment repo config repo is the
repository that we're looking at right
now it is meant to contain human
readable configurations at the right
level of abstraction to be defined by
your infrastructure team the deployment
repo contains the fully expanded
configurations that can be directly
applied to the actuation later in other
words it is a two-step process human
readable changes in the config repo will
be translated into machine readable
changes in the deployment repo and then
we'll be actuated now I'm going to
review and approve and merge the
requests it will take about a minute to
complete the entire process after the
Prada has been created let's go to the
product screen in the left pen here
there is a list of all the environments
associated with this product so right
now there's nothing in my dev
environment that's my next step I'm
going to create a new GK cluster so
other than the Machine type and node
count there is nothing else for me to
change that's because the very late team
has already predefined
the rest of the parameters and after I
hit the submit button it's going to
trigger the creation of another pull
request and then we can review it so the
first thing here on the pull request is
a terraform plan output that shows the
expected changes on the GCP side once
this pull request is merged if I scroll
down a little bit other than the G's ke
cluster configuration there's also the
configuration for the alert policies
again I did not define these they have
been created already by the very teams
and let's take a look at the yellow file
the ml file is pretty simple it only
contains the parameters that I just
entered in the web UI so I'm going to
approve this change emerge this requests
and the GK cluster should be ready in a
few minutes my GK cluster is ready to
serve now and I'm going to add a service
next at this point I should mention that
both a resource and service templates
are meant to be customized
there should be tailored mate to fit the
exact needs of your application team and
here I'm adding a java-based share RPC
service
and because I'm deploying this in my dev
environment I'm going to specify that a
new role will be created on every single
commit and now a pull request should be
generated and let's go ahead and review
it the interesting bit here is that
there is a repo URL field after this
pull request is merged it's going to
create a new repository of this location
and it's going to contain the simple
code
the server's creation has finished let's
take a look and this URL points to the
source repository that contains the
generated code and here we can see that
there are a few build related files and
if we look inside the source directory
we'll see that we have the protocol
buffer definition as well as the Java
skeleton code and because we specify -
we're all on every commit this initial
commit should generate a deployment on
my gke cluster here let's take a look at
the workflows page and the deployments
are already up and running and this
concludes our demo thank you welcome
back and thanks for the demo Tony as we
look forward to the rest of 2020 and
verily in the cloud we have a few
projects in mind first we want to work
towards enabling prototyping playgrounds
for developers as I said previously
we've enabled a lot of iam best
practices and GCP org policies in our
organization hierarchy to kind of keep
data safe and secure by default but this
slows down the great development
velocity we get when when we use the
cloud and so we want to be able to
enable playground life cycles and and
make sure that developers can easily
deploy a project and try some things
that are going through a large exemption
process looking towards app Factory
we're working to make templated generic
applications independent of language or
framework it being able to be deployed
we want to focus on test infrastructure
adding integration and load testing that
are easy to set up work just we want to
work to support more cloud resources and
and this is just increasing the breadth
of GCP resources we have as well as
looking potentially to multi cloud being
able to flex to where our partners are
we want to be able to customize release
management name custom environments add
additional environments and change
release pipelines to suit developer
needs and finally more generic automatic
monitoring setup so that when people set
up a project it's just
how's that monitoring and telemetry
available for them from the get-go and
so that's what we have for you today if
you're interested in anything we talked
about or using the tools that Google
errs and alphabet use to speed up their
public cloud adoption efforts please
reach out to dump Platts the alphabet
cloud product manager and thank you so
much for joining us today